[Musique]
vas-y quel talent à cela on dit d'animer
plateau c'est tahar bala les
chroniqueurs sont là n'ont pas bougé
maxime est là ouais mais bon nos lots et
la toile et voir la reine des neiges
comment ça qu'il fait hier avec un petit
comme ça bonhomme de neige
c'est plus eux maxime gagné l'année
dernière à ces eaux là c'est là haut la
main je veux pas spoiler film un moment
tu crois qu'ils meurent en fait ils
meurent pas parce qu'en fait ils les
aiment et n'aiment crise ya passe nulle
part c'est à double passe c'est que des
nains n'y apas lecoeuvre
je trouve très pur c'est vrai oui c'est
dingue c'est comme un fruit on voit
comme ça il est pur et quand on ouvre il
est pourri deux minutes je vais partir
en clientèle h et une urgence coiffure
je repartirai omelette norvégienne de
[ __ ] j'entendais des galériens
d'amertume frère c'est des sumos
marocain mon frère
elle est tellement mignon d'honneur
envie de la bouffe et cette petite 4e 4
4 ce chiffre 4 tibouchi c'est sa tête
monsieur calvi votre silence 4,4
faillite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait c est comme la météo pas vous
transformer le plateau en cours de
récréation voilà un nouveau couple qui
bat de l aile dans le monde merde jamais
la cour qui battait matters peu van
goolen n'ai pas compris
[Musique]
c'est toi qui pue du cul c'est toi dans
ton cul ya des jolies
[Musique]
naturex est ce n'est jamais un hasard
malraux exactement merci un échec aussi
j'avais des lunettes en titane très
légère et souvent prenez pour de la rue
ouais mais c'est à dire avec qui j'étais
et à toi tes côtés de l'armée petit et
de l'impasse pour votre première fois
vous êtes senti comme en tant que no
comment de sa super fière elle animera
des étoiles dans les yeux
bach pas de réel avec des étoiles
partout la bassée n'est pas fini moi ça
on en parle j'en ai donc pris mon zizi
beaucoup bossé sa comédie aux plus de 20
ans aussi je crois
et moi j'avais tenté ma chance avec le
skate jumain du village du club lève les
bras de zone ouais nan parce que je
croyais que j'avais mis un ballon de
basket dans ton slip voilà autant pour
moi merci
certes au malawi et au probable
[Musique]